but when you're in a scene when i'm in a
scene with somebody
and
something cool happens something happens
in an improved moment that neither one
of us expected or
the director's like you know i think
we're going to try this in a wonder and
let's see if we can make it work and you
pull it off right like just that stuff
feels so good the the overwhelming joy
for me of being on star trek as a star
trek fan and walking in to there's a
place on stage nine where you could walk
in the corridor of the enterprise at
kind of the curvature of the saucer
section of the enterprise you could walk
into it between the transporter room and
engineering and you could get in there
and there's this point in the corner
where you can't see anything else all
you can see
is i'm inside the enterprise 15 year old
me 16 year old me went there as often as
i could to stay there and pretend that
it was real like i loved that i loved
all of it but everything else
the auditioning the politicking the
inherent predatory toxic nature of so
many people who are in positions of
power in this industry
i hated all of it i you expressed this
to your mother i did over and over and
over again and there was a point in my
life
i just gave in
i just gave up and it would have been
it would it would have been like stand
by me changed everything and it would
have been right after stand by me
i literally went to bed and woke up the
next morning i went to bed totally
anonymous and woke up the next morning
and the four of us were like the
stranger things kids like it happened
literally overnight
and what is that feeling like that you
recall
could you could you walk down the street
yeah i mean that eventually changed
right you know that took a little bit of
time right
i don't remember exactly when this
happened
but it was after stand by me and it was
before star trek
i went to magic mountain with some
friends right
and
kind of got mobbed by teenaged girls
and i didn't like it you didn't i didn't
like it at all and how old are you i'm
probably
i'm at least 13 right maybe on my maybe
a little bit closer to 14. so you just
want to be with your friends and enjoy
it right here's the thing about that
right
you